(audience cheering)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Hello.
So, the last time you were here,
it was virtual.
- Yes.
- And you were in like a magical
place, like your backyard.
I just wanna show this picture,
again, because it's awesome.
What?
Looks like you're either, I don't know,
you could be in Texas or on a safari,
I don't know where the hell you are,
but it's like, it's so nice.
Do you miss doing interviews like that?
- I-I enjoyed it very much.
- Yeah.
- You didn't even have to,
- Its the,
wear pants.
- I wasn't.
- You can wear shorts.
- It's the production
value that, that I was like
well, aren't you gonna say
anything about the beard?
Look at that.
- I love the beard game.
- Whaa, yeah.
- I know, I know,
I love the beard game.
(audience applauds)
The beard game was my favorite.
I was literally telling
in my audience, I was like
"if I had your beard, man,
I would just be combing it
all day long."
I love beard game.
But y'all, you like to travel,
you and your wife, right?
- Yes, very much.
- And I think,
last time y'all were doing a trip to Napa.
- Yes.
- I think, was it,
was it lovely?
- Yeah, we did have a good time.
We went down and we saw
her, uh, we saw her father,
and, um, we had a, we
had a very good time.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Hi.
- We, we like to travel
together a lot.
We, we've been married for
27 years and we really-
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Kyle] Wait, that's like
striking out the pitcher.
That was the easiest,
that was the easiest applause.
Uh, but, um, no, we've
been married for 27 years
and now it's that time, you know,
the kids have stepped outta the house
and we have more time to
spend together and so.
- [Kelly] Get to date again.
- We do.
- I like it.
- And so we found, we, we had
a plan to, to do some trips
and one of them was to go to Spain,
to do the Camino de Santiago,
which is a, a trail that
takes you from, uh, France,
on the, the, the French
side of the Pyrenees,
and you go over to Spain,
then you go to Santiago de Compostela,
which is about a 500 mile walk, and um.
- So it is true, there
is someone for everyone.
(laughter)
- Well, I didn't know whether we'd last,
to tell you the truth.
- [Kelly] I was like...
- You walk with someone
for 500 miles, that's, uh,
that's a problem.
- [Kelly] No, just walking
for 500 miles in general sounds like,
unless there's wine, um,
(chuckles)
well, how did the trip go?
Did it, did you,
- It was great.
It was fantastic.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- We didn't,
- [Kelly] Beautiful, probably.
- We didn't make it the whole
way because I ended up with,
with shin splints, but beside that,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The first day was
walking over the Pyrenees.
The second day was moving
on through Spain and,
- [Kelly] Wow.
- We did about 220 miles, and
- [Kyle] it was incredible.
- [Kelly] Dang.
And it was fun, too
because first you gotta
get your backpack, you gotta
get all your parts together
and this and that and.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Oh, that's the part I like, the prep.
- And I was-
- Buying' all the fun stuff.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- You get to buy all the stuff
- [Kelly] Yeah.
and pack it up.
- And I was all excited about,
I told her I've got it all planned out.
We're gonna have our bags, you know,
taken from spot to
spot, to hotel to hotel,
and it's gonna be great.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she goes,
"We're not doing that."
- What?
- I said, "What do you mean?"
She goes, "Well we're just
gonna stay wherever we stay."
I said, "Where's that gonna be?"
She goes, "I don't know."
She goes, "Maybe the, the, the,
the albergues or the hostels
or wherever, that's where we'll stay."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I said -
- [Kelly] I love that free spirited.
(chuckles)
Yeah.
- No, I said, "No."
(laughter)
"No, are you cra-,"
I said, "Are you nuts?"
But, that's what we did
because she said yes
and it was a blast.
We had the time of our lives.
- [Kelly] I love that,
being unplanned, like its,
(audience applauds)
it's like planned but unplanned,
like you, I just love that
you're staying in a hostel.
- That's, that's it.
That was my top bunk.
And, and she stayed on the other top bunk
and the people behind,
below us that night,
you remember that, Kath?
They were not happy people.
(audience laughs)
They were, they were not happy.
- [Kelly] Because they
didn't get top bunk?
- [Kyle] No, I think they were just tired.
They were tired.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, um,
- [Kelly] That's a lot of,
- We had a great time.
- That's a, that's a, that's a close space
with a lot of strangers, yeah.
- It was many nights of that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You never knew what you
were gonna get, but they're also
beautiful hotels,
- [Kelly] Kind of fun.
along the way,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- that were, you know, from
centuries back and, uh,
whether they were old nunneries
or a beautiful little castle.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was just, it was amazing.
- [Kelly] It was interesting to me
to find out about all those
old castles or cathedrals,
like people that started building them.
Like I read Pillars of the Earth years ago
and I was like, oh my gosh,
people that started building
those, they didn't see the end.
They didn't see it come to fruition.
It took like over a hundred years.
- Right, right.
- You know, so,
the people that started
didn't get to finish it.
It's such a, a beautiful thing
to have that kind of artistry,
like those artisans were crazy talented.
- It's amazing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So, um, you have a charity, right?
- I do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, what is it?
- It's called
Patriots' Hall of Dripping Springs,
and it's, uh, out in, out
in Texas where we are.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's 10 acre retreat,
and it's for veterans and
families to come together
and connect and, you know,
there's a resource base for them.
There's an obstacle course, fishing pond,
all these things that.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Um, there's so many veterans
and families in Texas.
The densest amount is actually kind of
right where we're in the center of.
- Mmm.
- [Katherine] And just for
them to get off the computers
and get off things like that
and actually come together
and, you know, cook and get therapy,
all these kind of things.
So, that was our, my brainchild.
And then, the community
has just stepped up.
I mean, it's amazing when you
ask community, not government
and corporations, can you give to this?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's just changed
our entire community, they're so involved
and it's, it's awesome.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] I love that mentality
of having the community and I think,
I grew up in a small town
in Texas and it's like,
I'm used to that.
That's a really cool thing you're doing.
Thank you for sharing that.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Just so we can spread the word.
- Um, did you watch a lot of movies?
Because you're in so many movies
and things that people love.
Did you watch a lot with
your family, like your kids,
growing up?
- I did.
I, um, all the things that I loved
and that we watched together.
There's two mistakes I
made, that I think maybe
a lot of parents make,
one, with the older daughter,
the first time we watched
Old Yeller together.
- You?
- [Kyle] I did that.
- You showed her Old-?
- It wasn't smart, I know it wasn't.
She didn't talk to me for a long time.
- Such a sad movie.
- [Kyle] And then the second
one I did to the little kid,
the second child, um,
it was a Western and it was John Wayne.
You gotta watch John.
- Yeah.
- John Wayne's the greatest.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- And she's like, "okay."
- Yeah, right, he's the best.
- Yeah.
- And she's like, you know, well,
"Everything's gonna be
okay, right, no one dies?"
"Yeah, no one dies, it's John Wayne."
It was The Cowboys.
(audience laughs)
He dies in that.
Ohh, then she's all
mad at me for that one.
So, those are the two movies I failed at.
But we watch a lot of the, you know,
old Abbott and Costellos.
- Yeah.
- Chiti-Chiti-Bang-Bang and you know,
- Oh, that's cool.
- all the great stuff.
So, and we, we all watch a lot of movies,
like everyone does.
- [Kelly] Do you ever watch
movies with your kids?
Especially when they were
younger and you're like,
"Yeah, I love The Goonies."
So, you show your kids The Goonies
and you're like, "aghhh,"
because you're like,
I don't remember all this cursing
or I don't remember all the, like,
I didn't remember the
movie, like, it, like,
you watch as an adult.
- There are a few movies
from the seventies
- that that happened.
- [Kelly] I know!
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
- Like, all these movies,
I'm like, trying to show my kids,
like, connect with them and
I'm like, mm, maybe we'll wait.
(chuckles)
- [Kyle] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was like, "Yeah."
Um, but anyway, the, the new movie,
I gotta get to it, because I,
- [Kyle] Yes.
- I had a date night.
I wrote that in your card, I
don't know if you got it yet,
but I had a date night
with my son last night,
and he's six and he does not like,
he was always like, ugh, are
these real people movies?
Because he's, he likes animation, right?
So I'm like,
I swear I think you're
gonna like this one, buddy.
I read the synopsis, I think
you're really gonna like it.
He was glued to the screen.
- That's great.
- [Kelly] As I was.
- And it is, I'm not kidding,
like I would say this,
I said this this morning, my producer,
we both watched it last night.
It is one of my favorite movies I've seen
in a very long time.
- [Kyle] It's a good one, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Like, you know why?
It's, it's beautiful, aesthetically.
Like, it's so well done.
But also, it just comes
down to like, the story.
The story and how it
unfolds, and, and also like,
I don't know how y'all
handle this, but my kids
are six and eight and
like, death is like a thing
that they're terrified of.
- Mmhmm.
- And it's, and it
covers this whole topic,
and I was like, oh my gosh,
any parent that asks me,
"How do you talk to
your child about death?"
I'm just gonna tell 'em
to watch this movie.
It was a beautiful film.
- It, and, and Francis Lawrence
is a very good director.
- He's a wonderful gentleman,
- [Kelly] Gah.
and the young lady who acts in it,
- Marla, yeah.
- [Kyle] She was great.
- Gah.
- [Kyle] She was great,
- Yeah.
- And uh, obviously
Jason Momoa's fantastic
and everyone was great in it
and, um, it had all the
elements that you want
in a film like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And for myself,
when I first read it, um, you know, uh,
why do you do a film like
that and what gets you?
And when I first read it,
I got pretty emotional.
- Oh.
- [Kyle] Because, you know,
uh, she loses her pop
at an early age.
- Mmm.
- And so, same thing happened to me.
- So, you get to
turn that around.
And so, I was really excited
to be able to do a film
like that, and I like
doing films that, that,
that have that, you know,
it was a real joy to do it.
I'm real proud of it.
And it is a great movie.
- It is a great movie.
And you know what, it's interesting
that you just said that,
how you connect to it,
because I think, it,
watching this as a child
might have helped you.
You know what I'm saying,
like, watching a child
with that kind of loss, like,
even to know that you're
not alone in those emotions
and how to handle and grief
and like all those things
and, and how to process
and not to compartmentalize
and escape, like it's just, it's,
it's such a fantastic movie for kids.
I'm making, it is very
deep, but it's also,
my six-year-old did not leave.
He made me pause it to pee.
(laughter)
He made me pause it.
He made me pause it anytime he left
to go get water or anything.
He was like, "No, no, no, I
don't wanna miss anything."
But it was very refreshing.
- Has a lot of heart to it.
- It was very refreshing.
(audience applauds)
It has a lot of heart and
it's like a fresh story.
I did not know that it was a comic.
Was it a comic strip?
Like, back in-
- It was originally.
- I didn't know that.
- It was, um, Winslow McCay,
I think is his name.
Back in 19, uh, 1905 to 1911,
he was doing the original comic strip
and he was a famous animator, as well,
because he's got some of the
earliest animation from, uh,
uh, animation documentaries,
one being the Sinking of the Lusitania,
um, Gertie the Dinosaur,
if you remember the original.
- Yeah.
- [Kyle] He's, that's him.
And then, he worked back and
forth with the Hearst papers
until '26 when, when it all
stopped and what he did,
but it went for quite a long time,
and, uh, um, the storylines are fantastic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- If you see the,
the books are wonderful to look at.
The architecture and the,
the comic strips are amazing.
- Yeah
- He experimented.
It was, he was, he was
really at the forefront
of a lot of things.
- I haven't seen the original,
but I'm saying, "pfft."
What y'all did in that film and
like, going into each dream,
and I loved, um, the character,
even your relationship with your daughter,
it was so special.
- [Kyle] It was.
- [Kelly] Very, very cool.
- It's very nice to do.